it's interesting because it's almost
like people get angry at you if you're
mature if you mature past the the the
obvious immaturity that is comes with
the same culture the street [__] if you
think about it is extremely it's like an
immature lifestyle right you're supposed
to be extremely reactive to things that
normal people wouldn't be reactive to
and it's like yo if I already got
through that part of my life and I'm
still here and I don't know yo I'm I'm
growing up now like like yeah what the
[__] is it and it's like I saw people
giving Jeezy [__] because like he was
like the bigger man with the Gucci [__]
I don't know man Jesus Jeezy sold out
I'm like what did you want Jeezy to do
that you you want Jeezy to not wear a
suit and go do a podcast and write a
book and like it's like you you know
like I mean
he went over whatever he was gonna do
but at the end of the day wake up
supposed to fight the [__] for the
world right there and Gucci Gucci's come
out and said he kind of regretted how he
handled that yeah yeah so it's like at
the end of the day because Gucci feel
like a kid his girl told him you you
kind of yeah I mean that's when when you
had that conversation with your wife and
everything like hey that was kind of
childish like yeah damn you think so
like yeah I mean like because
that [__] ain't 25 28 no more like it
ain't yeah I mean [__] ain't even that
[__] ain't even it doesn't add up like
you want me to keep on standing outside
either selling drugs or holding guns
whatever the case is you know what I'm
saying like because you're not gonna be
there and don't be protected whatever it
is at 35 and keep going to jail making
and also rather than me starting a
career yeah and doing what the [__] I'm
doing and elevating like yeah I'm gonna
choose that over anything right yeah
because at the end of the day who are
who are you to your children like yeah
yeah for real who are you to your kids
that's all you should worry about like
who are you to your children as long as
you taking like these are people that
and not all of them but the people that
they want us to to be like are you going
to jail you missing out on your kids
like it's no way that you're taking care
of your kids to your full possible like
your capability if you incarcerated if
you on parole all the time if you got to
check in here you can't go here you
can't take them to this tournament out
here you can't do this you get what I'm
saying it's so many restrictions that
the streets put in your life like and I
I got uh that out my mind song where I
say I'm one foot in the game one foot
out like I'm thinking about going all in
in the blind like going legit and been
crossing my mind like I I I was just
talking about me just being in the
streets and like [__] I said the
streets Hold Me Back have been blocking
my shine like you get what I'm saying
like at the end of the day
everything that comes to the end comes
to the end because of the street ties
and the [__] gang never gave the
legal Lane a shot ever you get what I'm
saying and and you have an opportunity
to give it a real shot so why can't a
[__] put everything into it like I put
everything into the streets because
guess what if you're one foot in one
foot out that's just gonna follow you to
wherever you're trying to get the legal
[__] together that's what I'm trying to
tell you so it's like you gotta it's not
bounce out the streets or oh disconnect
from oh I'm not from here no more or
whatever it's like I'm forever gonna be
who I am yeah you get what I'm saying
but that [__] can't control
a hundred percent of my day no more 100
like every everybody's opinion it can't
like I'm a grown-ass man you could talk
to them kids like that and try to get
them together I didn't already went
tested and approved and been through all
that little [__] right there you're not
about to try to run me through the
ringer like [__] yeah I mean
I'm not even going for that I don't even
respond like [__] man you know you
can't do that